"California Gurls"?
I wish they all could be...
No, it's a new one.
A new song?
Yes. Katy Perry and Snoop Dogg...
Uh-huh!
...and it's just kind of like a song about the West Coast.
See, Snoop Dogg is like my generation.
Oh, really?
He's coming back, I guess.
Yeah.
Are you surprised?
And how is it then?
So, Snoop Dogg... you recommend this song "California Gurls" by Katy Perry and Snoop Dogg?
Yeah.
The lyrics are just kind of like,...
...her lyrics are kind of like, different, you know, like "I Kissed a Girl" and stuff like that...
...or just kind of like, different, extreme, sort of like, in the whole America sense thing, but...
...it goes like, "California girls, we're unforgettable."
"Daisy Dukes, bikinis on top. Sun-kissed skin, so hot we'll melt your popsicle."
Awesome, "We'll melt your popsicle", good luck translating that.
Awesome!
Well, thanks so much for the interview.
Thank you!
And as a member of the Japanese listening public, we just want you to know, you're ill!
You're ill!
You're pretty ill also.
Thanks! We should both go to the hospital.
Yeah!